>> MORE WORDS HEATING UP BETWEEN
ANTHONY SCAR A USUALLY
ANTHONY SCARAA USUALLY
ANTHONY SCARAMUUSUALLY
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCUALLY
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCIALLY
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI ALY
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP AFTER TRUMP'S VISIT TO EL
PASO.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
A CHANGE AT THE TOP OF THE
TICKET WHEN SOMEONE IS ACTING
LIKE THIS.
>> THE MINUTE YOU SAY SOMETHING
HE DOESN'T LIKE, HE FIGURES HE
CAN INTIMIDATE YOU LIKE A BULLY.
THERE IS PAPER
THERE IS AAPER
THERE IS A EER
THERE IS A EVIL TO DIVIDE THE
COUNTRY.
>> AND TRUMP'S WORDS BACK.
HE HAS TWEETED:
>> DANA?
>> SO NOW SCARAMUCCI IS ON TV.
HE'S ON TV A LOT.
>> I TALKED TO SCARAMUCCI.
HE SAID ONE OF THE THINGS HE'S
UPSET ABOUT IS THE CRITICISM
THAT GO BACK.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS MORE TO
IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS, THESE ARE BOTH PEOPLE
THAT ARE QUITE LIKEABLE ON TV.
TRUMP AND SCARAMUCCI.
THE MOOCH WAS NOT FOR TRUMP IN
2016.
THEN WAS FOR TRUMP AND NOW ISN'T
FOR TRUMP.
I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE IT'S SIN
SKIER.
I THINK THEY COULD POTENTIALLY
PATCH THINGS UP IN THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS.
WOULDN'T THAT BE A REUNION.
SCARAMUCCI HAS POINTED OUT THEY
MAY HAVE TO REPLACE HIM.
DO YOU KNOW HE FOLLOWED TODAY ON
TWITTER?
MARK STANFORD.
FORMER REPUBLICAN FROM SOUTH
CAROLINA.
HE HAS HIS TOE IN THE WATER.
>> SINCE HE MARRIED THE TWEET
NOW SAYING THE 2020 CHALLENGE,
THAT D. THAT END THEM GETTING
BACK TOGETHER THERE.
>> I THINK, I THINK THE REAL
HOUSEWIVES THING DIDN'T PAN OUT.
SCARAMUCCI GOT THE BUG, THE FILM
BUG.
THE SPOTLIGHT BUG THAT THE MONEY
CAN'T SATISFY.
HE'S LIKE A MEERKAT.
HE SEES THE SPOT LIGHT, THE
MEERKATS PICK UP.
THAT'S THE MOOCH.
I HAVE A SPORTS ANALOGY, YOU
WON'T GET IT MAYBE JUAN.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE AL DAVIS AS
PRESIDENT.
HE RAN THE OAKLAND RAIDERS IN
THE 70s.
HE HAS A MOTTO "WIN BABY."
HE ATTRACTED ROUGH, SCARY AND
WEIRD PEOPLE.
THAT WAS THE ENTIRE OAKLAND
RAIDERS.
YOU GET THESE WEIRD THIRD
STRINGERS.
NOT THE BEST JUDGMENT CALLS ON
TRUMP'S PART.
THEY GET IN UNDER THE GUYS OF
LOYALTY AND IF IT DOESN'T TURN
OUT THEY TURN ON YOU.
>> I WAS THINKING THIS EARLIER.
ONLY THE BEST PEOPLE BY THE WAY.
AMAROSE SAID HE WAS A LOW LIFE.
AND THEN HE CALLED HER A DOG.
I DON'T KNOW BUT REX TILLERSON
SAID HE WAS A MORON.
THIS IS REMORSE, BUYER'S REMORSE
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANTED IN ON THE
POWER DEAL, VISIT THE WHITE
HOUSE, THE TITLE AND IMPORTANT
JOB.
THEY GOT THE JOB BUT AT SOME
POINT THEY'RE LIKE, MAYBE THIS
WASN'T A GOOD IDEA SCARAMUCCI,
WHAT IS INTERESTING --
>> HE GOT FIRED FOR DOING THAT
STUPID DRUNKEN PHONE CALL.
>> TO A MEMBER OF THE PRESS.
>> LEAKING.
>> I SAY DRUNK IN NOT SAYING
WHAT I REALLY THINK HE'S ON.
>> SCARAMUCCI, WHAT YOU SAY NOW
IS TRUE WHY WASN'T IT TRUE
BEFORE YOU TOOK THE JOB?
HE WENT AFTER McCAIN, HE WENT
AFTER MEXICO.
>> I THINK SCARAMUCCI THOUGHT HE
COULD HELP.
HE WAS GOING TO GO INTO
COMMUNICATIONS --
>> THEY ALL THINK THAT, DANA.
TILLERSON THOUGHT THAT MANY.
>> SCARAMUCCI TURNED ON HIM NOT
TRUMP TURNING ON SCARE A PHAOUFP
TRUMP TURNING ON SCARE A PHAOUFS
TRUMP TURNING ON SCARE A PHAOUFA
TRUMP TURNING ON SCARE A PHAOUFU
TRUMP TURNING ON SCARE A PHAOUFC
TRUMP TURNING ON SCARE A PHAOUF.
>> SCARAMUCCI WANTS AND NEEDS
ATTENTION.
IT'S CHILLY AND COLD IN THE
SHADE WHEN YOU'RE IGNORED BY THE
MEDIA.
HOW DO YOU GET THAT BIG RAY OF
SUNSHINE TO SHINE ON YOU FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK THE BAIT.
HE TOOK THE BAIT.
HE FIRED BACK AT HIM
IMMEDIATELY.
I WILL POINT THIS OUT.
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI SUPPORTED
OBAMA IN 2008.
HE WENT TO LAW SCHOOL.
THEN HE FLIPPED AND SUPPORTED
MITT ROMNEY.
HATED ON PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THEN SUPPORTED HIM.
HIS FINNINGER IS IN THE AIR,
HE'S LOOKING WHICH WAY THE WIND
IS BLOWING.